how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything
relating to the mcu now the mcu has been
rather odd lately in fact the entire pop
culture community has been rather odd
due to kobit 19.
a lot of movies and shows that we were
highly anticipating were pushed back
unfortunately but one of the biggest
hits that we got of the year was san
diego comic-con
was canceled and this of course is
pretty much the biggest
event of the year for all the pop
culture fans and especially marvel fans
for example last year in 2019
marvel unveiled their entire phase 4
slate
so there was a lot of hopes that we
would get something this year from san
diego comic-con as well
but it was cancelled and instead they
decided to do comic con at home
but unfortunately marvel studios decided
not to participate
so this was unfortunate but over the
weekend inside scooper mikey sutton has
released several
reports one i got to exclusively report
on saturday about captain marvel 2 and
another
one through the lords of the long box
talking about the fantastic
four in the mcu marvel's first family a
team that we've been waiting to appear
at marvel studios not fox for a very
long time now so marvel studios can get
them right
and based off of this report from lords
of the long box it sounds like the
fantastic four are going to be done in a
way that has never been done before and
we'll break it all down
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things relating to the mcu and
big congratulations to youtube user kv
mcu for being last week's winner of the
hawkeye funko pop giveaway just email me
in the email in my description and i'll
get you your prize
and for this week's giveaway it's going
to be a scarlet witch funko pop so all
you got to do is like the video
subscribe and leave a comment
down below so as i mentioned this report
originally comes from
the lords of the long box provided by
mikey sutton i'll put a link for their
channel
down below and let's talk about what
they had to say the report goes
as follows the fantastic four is a
family and that means
more than just a husband a wife a
brother and a best friend
in the mcu kevin feige wants a fresh
look at the fantastic four
one that pays homage to its comic book
roots but
one that adds a little bit more polish
than what fox did with their fantastic
four
having initially attempted to do the
fantastic four right but ultimately
failed according to mikey sutton his
sources say that there will be no
waiting in the marvel cinematic universe
for
franklin richards the son of sue storm
and reed richards and also one of the
most
powerful omega-level mutants that the
marvel universe has ever seen
according to mikey sutton marvel
studios's plan is to have franklin
richards with the fantastic
four from the very beginning and
immediately the fantastic four will look
different than any
other superhero team that we've seen in
the marvel cinematic universe because
they will have a child and not just any
child but an omega level mutant and
one of the most powerful characters in
all of the marvel
universe's history for example at one
point in time he even
resurrects a dead galactus and he then
commands him
as a puppet to fight the celestials with
him and they both defeat them
with ease but the news doesn't stop
there according to sutton marvel would
then like to spin off franklin richards
for
a power pack disney plus series
something that we've heard about now for
a pretty long time
but now we know that franklin richards
is going to be a part of this project
as well and that is mikey's report again
coming from lords of the long box
so this is actually a really great way
to introduce the fantastic four with
them already having
franklin richards and this also means
that we're not going to get
a typical origin story with the
fantastic
four it could almost be like a
spider-man homecoming type of film we
didn't see
peter get bit by the spider or perhaps
like captain marvel it was kind of an
origin story but they did it in a very
different
unique way that was quite enjoyable now
there's no doubt that they'll definitely
go over how they got their powers in the
marvel cinematic universe and what
they've been up to this entire time
while the avengers were defending the
earth because if they're going to
introduce the fantastic four with
already having franklin richards that
means they've most likely had their
powers for a pretty long time
unless they do decide to change their
origin just a little bit and perhaps
franklin richards gets his powers along
with his parents
his uncle and the thing and right now
there are
more than plenty of theories about how
the fantastic four could get their
powers in the mcu the most popular one
right now is that they could get them
from
the quantum realm the fantastic four in
the comics are deeply connected to
the negative zone and annihilus a
villain that we will most likely
see coming up within the next few years
of the mcu and it would be pretty easy
for marvel studios to simply turn the
negative zone
into the quantum realm and the quantum
realm is going to play a very big part
of the mcu moving forward it wasn't just
used for time travel in avengers end
game but we actually have confirmation
from marvel studios themselves that it's
going to be a big part of the future and
we're going to see it relatively soon
the biggest thing that we know about it
so far is the quantum
city that we saw in ant-man and the wasp
people at marvel themselves told us to
look out for this and told us that it is
going to be an important part of
future events this could be where
annihilus is hiding this could be where
the fantastic four could possibly be
trapped and that's where they end up
getting their powers from because
janet van dyne was trapped inside the
quantum realm and by the time that she
got out she said that she had sort of
evolved and now we saw that she had
specific powers she was able to heal
ghost there's so much we didn't know
about this place henry
worlds upon worlds entire civilizations
far
more than we ever theorized so perhaps
the fantastic four do end up getting
stuck
inside of the quantum realm and that's
how they get their powers in the mcu
not to mention this would start to
connect the fantastic four who have not
been in the mcu with other characters
that have been for a pretty long time so
there's a possibility that we could see
the fantastic four
in the next ant-man film ant-man 3. but
mikey sutton also reported in the past
through my youtube channel that
the illuminati are going to be making
their way to the mcu and recently we
have gotten new reports about
this as well but in mikey's original
report it said that the illuminati are
going to be making an appearance in
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness now for those of you who may not
know the lineup of the illuminati it's
iron man
doctor strange namor the submariner
black bolt
professor xavier and mr fantastic of the
fantastic
four now if this ends up being what
marvel studios decides to do
that means we will see not only
professor xavier and the x-men in phase
four but
the fantastic four mr fantastic and
phase four as well
and this means that the x-men and the
fantastic four are not too far away from
their official
marvel cinematic universe debut at 2019
san diego comic con kevin feige did
mention the fantastic four and he did
mention the mutants so we know that
marvel studios has definitely already
begun their plans of what they plan to
do to introduce them and what stories
they want to tell
now recently we have gotten some other
reports concerning the fantastic four
from
roger wardell or at least an account
claiming to be him
roger wardell was the person who leaked
a ton of information about avengers
in-game and phase 4
all of which ended up being correct now
his old account hasn't posted in a bit
and there's a new account that has
arised and which he says
is his new account because he got kicked
out of his old account there's no way to
really know but he was 100
accurate about all of the other leaks in
the past so hopefully it is him but
take this information with a grain of
salt but in recent reports he has said
that john
krasinski and emily blunt who everybody
wants to play mr fantastic
and the invisible woman are in fact
being courted for mcu roles
but not the fantastic four marvel is
looking at fresh faces for the first
family he says that names that are being
thrown around to play at reed richards
in the mcu include
lakeith stanfield and matthew gray
gubler
but another very interesting thing in
this report is that he says
after two decades peyton reed will
finally get his hands on the fantastic
four
but not in a fantastic four film
now for those of you who are unaware
peyton reed directed ant-man
and ant-man and the wasp but something
that you may not know is that he has
wanted to direct and write a fantastic
four film for a
very very long time in fact years ago he
wrote a fantastic four script
that took place in the 1960s and he
pitched it to fox
now obviously since we don't have that
movie it did not get made
but he's been wanting to write and
direct a fantastic four film for a while
and this report says that he's going to
get his chance but it's not going to be
a fantastic four
film well since he's directed ant-man 1
and ant-man of the wasp and is going to
direct ant-man 3 there's a high
possibility that we could see the
fantastic
four in ant-man 3. this is what the
report would mean by he would get to
direct the fantastic four but it
wouldn't be a film it will be ant-man 3
and the fantastic four will be in the
film and as i mentioned before there are
plenty of ways to
introduce the fantastic four in ant-man
3 especially when we're going to be
talking about the quantum realm and not
to mention we still don't know
what the building and spider-man far
from home was
there was the fantastic four teaser in
front of this new building that said
we can't wait to show you what comes
next along with the numbers
one two three and then nothing implying
that
four the fantastic four are what's
coming next so the building the new
avengers tower and spider-man far from
home could be the baxter building the
home
to the fantastic four and that timing
kind of aligns the events of spider-man
3
and the events of ant-man 3. so bringing
them into ant-man 3 having them take
their baxter building in downtown new
york would all fit perfectly
in the marvel cinematic universe as it
is right now and as it will
be so let me know what you think about
this new report about the fantastic four
coming to the mcu
with franklin richards one of the most
powerful characters that marvel has ever
seen
let me know what you think in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all
mcu related news for live updates you
can follow me on twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof